clubhouse
let's look into what it is who's funded
it and where is it going
first what is it well basically it's an
audio based social media app
many people can go visit a room and
listen to people talk
and you could raise your hand and
actually participate in the conversation
on that topic
moderators can choose to call on you if
you've raised your hand or not
so think of it as listening to a podcast
with a thousand other people
and saying i'd like to contribute to the
conversation and then having a moderator
that lets you do so
that's what it is if you're like me and
you're a little older
maybe you remember am radio where you
could call in on the talk sports show
and talk on the radio and you would sit
there and wait in your car on the phone
for 20 minutes until they let you get in
it was on a five second delay in case
you said a bad word
and then you could talk to the jock the
radio
host for a few minutes or a few seconds
as they went through things and they
could hang up on you and go the next guy
really quick
it's sort of that in the digital age
it's not terribly complicated
but it's exploding let's take a look at
the history
clubhouse is less than a year old here
we've got
january 2020 when basically a little bit
of seed capital comes together and these
two guys
paul davidson and rohan seth build the
app
paul davidson you may remember created
something called highlight
and highlight was bought by pinterest so
this gentleman
is accustomed to being in the social
media space
and he's also had an exit already he
gets together with rohan
seth and clubhouse is born clubhouse
started out
with a launch only in april of last year
and it was only on ios
in may they received 10 million dollars
from andreessen horowitz
and they created a waiting list so in
other words the initial buzz was created
by depriving people of their ability to
get something that was sounding
interesting and was getting a little
juice in the market getting a little
buzz
but you couldn't get in unless you were
invited and the invitation had to come
from someone who was already
in and when there's only a few people
and you didn't know any of them
that meant you were on the outside on a
waiting list for a good while
meanwhile silicon valley insiders people
that knew each other
founders of companies were jumping in
which was actually
key because now you have a lot of high
wattage individuals
who know what they're talking about are
relatively famous sort of business
celebrities
and they're the folks that you and i
would want to hear talk about business
topics or any other topic for that
matter
and then have us be able to chime in
with them so the waiting list
and who was getting in actually helps
the seed future success
the app continues to gain just
barely a little under a million users by
the end of
2020. that was like november december
time frame
and then suddenly in january
it pops up to 2 million users
now a short time later it blows the lid
off
but what happened well elon musk drops
in that's right
elon musk was in he's one of the early
users and he imaginatively takes
at elon musk at clubhouse
i pointed out that the compression that
happens these days
when an app goes viral is com is
actually compressing the compression
period
to virality where the amount of time it
takes to grow
compresses with the viral nature of an
app
is phenomenal well this has happened in
just
jet speed then after raising only 10
million dollars
they go out at a 1 billion dollar
valuation
and raise a hundred million dollars also
involving
andreessen horowitz so wait a minute let
me see if i understand this
this thing was started with seed funding
barely a year ago
and it was only on ios and only on
ios it got a 10 million dollar
investment from adreson horowitz that's
not huge
then thanks to a waiting list it kind of
grew at a moderate rate but these were
high quality individuals kind of a who's
who of silicon valley yep that's right
and then the thing goes to two million
and six million
just in 30 days right at the beginning
of the year suddenly having a one
billion dollar valuation
and a hundred million dollar investment
but led by andreessen horowitz
yes that's exactly what i said look at
the compression that's on here it's
amazing
and android is still on the outside
looking in
or looking up at the trajectory that
apple and ios is involving
now here's with something else here we
know that android on a global basis
has got an awful lot of phones and if
this
thing was to be on android i hope
they're ready for this kind of scaling
on the server base
and they don't melt the servers because
android on a global basis has quite the
footprint ah well poor android but
they'll get over it because there is a
clubhouse version coming for android
i just hope the servers are ready to
handle it thanks for watching the short
clip
if you like that and like to see the
whole episode you can find it right here
and for even more subscribe to this
channel
right here